MANUEL VIVO: In Android Q, we
are improving the ShareSheet.
We're introducing a new sharing
shortcuts API that makes
Direct Share lightning-fast.
Also, there is a
new content preview
for text, images, and files.
Direct Share is a
feature that allows
apps to show app-specific
options directly
in the ShareSheet.
Those options are called
Sharing Shortcuts.
For example, a
messaging app using it
can enable the user to share
content to a contact directly.
While the Direct Share
feature is still supported,
the legacy Direct Share
API is now deprecated.
Going forward, you will use
the new Sharing Shortcuts API.
Unlike the deprecated
APIs, Sharing Shortcuts
are published in advance, making
the ShareSheet load instantly
when launched.
This is similar to how the
ShortcutManner API works.
That's why we've
expanded the ShortcutInfo
API to make the integration
of both features easier.
The new Sharing
Shortcuts API is also
supported in the new
ShareTarget AndroidX library.
That makes Direct Share
backwards-compatible down
to Android M.
Taking into account that
sharing target's implemented
with the legacy
Direct Share API will
be deprioritized in
Android Q, meaning
that they will appear
after the ones published
with the new API.
Using the ShortcutManagerCompat
class from the support library
is the preferred way to
publish Sharing Shortcuts.
That will work on
older Android versions
without any extra work needed.
Follow these steps to publish
Sharing Shortcuts using
the new API.
First, declare share
target elements
in your shortcuts.xml file.
And add the metadata
to your main activity
in the Android manifest file.
Secondly, publish
dynamic shortcuts
to the already declared share
targets using this Shortcut
Manager API.
Lastly, to make it
backwards-compatible,
add this metadata tag
to the activity that
will handle the shared intent.
That's all.
Without Direct Share, this is
how your app would look like.
With the new changes and support
for the new content preview,
this is how the
ShareSheet has changed.
Now users can jump
straight into your app
when sharing content
from another app.
To find out more
about Direct Share,
check out the code lab
and the documentation.
All links below.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]